hello everyone there were a lot of
immortal games throughout chess history
but in this game the white player
sacrifice is literally all of his pieces
this game was played in 1993 between the
American Grand Master Gregory sir per
and the Greek Grandmaster your honesty
colitis so let's see this game sir / is
white and Yanis is black we have c-4 g6e
for Bishop to g7 d4 we have d6 Knight to
c3 Knight to f6 Knight G to E to Knight
B to d7 tonight to g3 c6 Bishop to e2 a6
Bishop to e3 h v f3 and b5 and as you
can see black is trying to play on both
sides of the board and this usually
doesn't end well so we have c5 d
captures on c5 d captures on c5 and
Queen to c7 and the white castles and
black pushes forward
he plays h4 and the force is the White
Knight all the way to h1 so Knight 2 h 1
we have tonight to h5 now going for that
f4 square so what prevents the C plays
Queen to d2 we have E 5 nights to F 2
night to f8 and with this night to f8
move black is preparing to develop the
bishop probably to e6 but why doesn't
allow this and with White's next move
white starts his well brilliant attack
where he sacrifices literally all of his
pieces sir / plays a 4 here we have b4
and now sir / plays Knight to d5
attacking the Queen and okay the knight
doesn't have to be the knight sacrifice
doesn't have to be accepted but if this
Knight gets to b6 then this will be
extremely good for white so black
captures seek after Sun d5e captures on
d5 and okay but a white now has the
these two nice pass pawns
black plays f5 and we have these six
with an attack on the Queen and Queen to
c6 and here white sacrifice is another
piece but this time the piece sacrifice
must be accepted plays Bishop to b5 now
pinning the Queen and King and well
since the black doesn't wanna part with
his queen he captures the bishop a
captures v5 and we have a capture some
b5 also now with an effect on the Queen
and also we're gonna tack on the rock on
a8 and here in this position black
should have played Queen to b7 but he
was probably afraid of these three
passed pawns and he played the Queen
capture some b5 he decides to give back
some material just to you know I really
if he is really the pressure I would
have rook captures on a 8 and now Queen
the c6 attacking the rook and rook F to
a 1 now doubling up on da file we have
f4 now attacking this Bishop here and
white plays rook a to a7 and well black
could capture the bishop here but this
would end pretty badly as this rook to
e7 check will be catastrophic for black
so first before capturing the bishop
black decides to play Knight to d7 now
this rook cannot go to e7 and now he
definitely is threatening to capture on
e3 but here white plays rook captures on
c8 a nice exchange sacrifice we have
Queen captures on c8 and now Queen to d5
a very nice centralizing move and well
he's preparing some ideas like like c6
we have F captures on e3 attacking the
knight and now white plays Queen to e6
and note that well even if black didn't
capture this Bishop on e3 there's really
no way no way to stop Queen to e6 check
so like black thought I might as well
capture the bishop so we have F captures
only three and now Queen to e6 check we
have King to f8 & okay white wins back
some material now rook captures on d7
and now black captures the knight with
tempo so he plays he captures and f2
with check and King to f1 we have Queen
to e8 and let's count the pieces here
okay White has a Queen and the rook and
black has a queen a bishop a knight and
the roof so he's up to pieces but why
does have this nice two best ones and
here white finds a way to sacrifice even
more material he plays rook the f7 check
now sacrificing the rook and rook must
be accepted we have Queen captures on c8
9 f8 and now Queen to see
check and the black king has nowhere to
go so the Queen must block this check so
Quinta ate and now a very nice move by
white he plays d7 and now of course the
Queen cannot be captured as the Queen is
captured and simply captures and c8
brings up another Queen
so black simply plays a king to f7 and
ok we have D captures any eight with
Czech rook captures any eight and Queen
to b7 check and rook to e7
but now white again uses his past pawn
and he plays c6 and black cannot capture
the Queen here because after C capture
some b7 there is no way to stop this
pawn from promoting so black plays efore
and now black is threatening to capture
the Queen because now after Queen is
captured and seek seek after Sun b7 then
he has this Bishop to e5 move protecting
and b8 so white simply plays c7 here and
we have III now black has a nice pass
pawn of his own white plays Queen to d5
check we have a king to f6 Queen to d6
check came to f7 and now white captures
the rook Queen okay first he repeats the
position he is probably going for going
for a move 40 to reach to reach 9
control
so again King to f6 Queen to d6 check
King to f7 and now time draws rich this
is move 41 and now he captures the rook
Queen captures on his seven would check
King captures on e7 and queen pawn to b8
upon c8 promoting to a queen and okay a
White has only a queen and black has the
knight and the bishop and these two very
nice pawns but unfortunately blacks
pieces are a bit too uncoordinated
we have Bishop to h6 and Queen to c5
check King to e8 Quinta b5 check King to
d8
now Queen to b6 check now finally
grabbing will grab this pawn on g6 king
37 and now Queen captures on on g6 now
attacking both Bishop and the night and
here black tries one more tactic before
resigning key place
II - which check King captures an F -
and now Bishop to e3 check and this is a
very nice move if for example if the
King were to capture this Bishop here
then simply you want promotes to a queen
and well black is winning here and even
if he doesn't capture the bishop if he
captures this pawn on e2 then simply
Knight to f4 check for King the king and
queen and this is also winning for black
so after this Bishop to e3 check a white
simply played King to e1 and in this
position black resigned so a very nice
game by a Gregory sir / and this is why
this game is called the mortal sacrifice
game because white managed to sacrifice
literally all of his pieces and it's
well it's not often to see a game like
this played between two grandmasters so
yeah that's it I do hope you enjoyed the
game and I would like to thank Mark Graf
and Bruce bedlam for contributions to my
channel I do appreciate it thank you
very much and that's it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
made also says hi and I'll see you soon